The MCU is more than a decade into its run,
but there are countless Marvel characters
whose origins still haven't been told on the
big screen.
So which characters actually deserve to make
the leap?
From Britain’s guardian to a worthy space
horse, here are the Marvel origin stories
we'd love to see on film.
Most of the X-Men's origin stories are simple.
They were born with the X-gene, developed
their uncanny mutant abilities in their teens
and then Professor X found them, or some version
of that.
Then there are the mutants who led rich, exciting
lives well before joining the X-Men, like
Wolverine, or Deadpool, or Gambit.
Two of those three have gotten their own films,
and a Gambit movie was in the works for years.
Then, Disney's purchase of Fox seemed to kill
it, and that's a shame, because his incredible
origin story definitely deserves some screen
time.
"Are you Remy Lebeau?"
"Do I owe you money?"
Remy LeBeau was abandoned as a baby because
part of his mutation, his glowing red eyes,
was already visible at birth.
He was then adopted as a kind of prophesied
savior by the New Orleans Thieves Guild and
was raised to be a master thief.
Then, an arranged marriage within the guilds
led to a duel, the murder of a member of the
Assassins Guild, and an excommunication from
the Thieves Guild, which ultimately brought
Remy to the X-Men.
It's complex, it's dramatic, and it's got
lots of opportunities for John Wick-style
action set in the heart of New Orleans.
Even if you're sick of origin story movies,
this one might win you over.
Sometimes the best way to lay out a superhero
origin story is to keep things as vague as
possible.
That's always been the case with the unbeatable
Squirrel Girl, a beloved heroine whose name
gives you a very good idea of her power set,
but doesn't really explain why she can take
down literally any bad guy in the Marvel Universe.
Doreen Green was born with a prehensile tail
that looks a whole lot like a squirrel's tail,
and as she grew up, she discovered she had
various other rodent-like abilities, including
the power to understand and speak to squirrels
themselves.
What really makes Squirrel Girl's origin particularly
interesting, though, is that Marvel has never
fully pinned down exactly where her powers
came from.
Though her genetic makeup is altered from
that of a normal human, she isn't technically
a mutant in the same way that members of the
X-Men are.
She's just ... different, and she's chosen
to use those differences for good.
Also, she managed to thoroughly defeat Doctor
Doom, one of the biggest bads of the entire
Marvel Universe, in her first appearance,
and she's pretty much been undefeated ever
since.
There's no way that a teenage girl with squirrel
powers taking down world-threatening supervillains
wouldn't make for a great on-screen origin
story.
Galactus, the nearly omnipotent "Devourer
of Worlds," has already appeared on the big
screen once, but Fantastic Four: Rise of the
Silver Surfer used an incarnation that more
closely a massive cloud of energy rather than
the omnipotent humanoid that we've seen in
the comics.
As the Fantastic Four prepare to enter the
MCU, it's time to give audiences the "real"
Galactus on the big screen, all while explaining
some of his epic cosmic background.
Galactus was born Galan of Taa, an explorer
from an advanced planet that was one of the
last remaining civilizations in the universe
that existed before ours.
As his native universe imploded due to a kind
of crunching effect to prepare for another
Big Bang, Galan decided to pilot a ship straight
into the heart of the "Cosmic Egg" that would
give birth to the next universe.
In short, he's the only survivor of the Big
Bang that created the Marvel universe as it
was first introduced in the 1960s.
Passing through that chaotic event led to
his rebirth as Galactus, a cosmic force of
nature scarier than Thanos who survived by
consuming the life force of entire worlds.
We'd love to see a character that grand and
paradigm-shifting in live-action.
The Hulk's hard-hitting gamma bombshell cousin
is about to get her own series on Disney+,
so there's a good chance we'll see some version
of She-Hulk's origin soon.
That said, we still want to take a moment
to talk about why her superhero foundation
is so great, and how it ties into the existing
MCU already.
Jennifer Walters was a meek but very intelligent
lawyer who just happened to be Bruce Banner's
favorite cousin, thanks to their childhood
friendship.
When a crime boss' thugs tried to gun her
down while she was protecting a witness, Bruce
struggled to save his cousin's life and realized
there was nothing he could do in the moment
but give her a transfusion of his own blood.
Bruce's gamma-irradiated blood, coupled with
the emotional stress of the danger she was
in, transformed Jennifer into She-Hulk.
Over the next few decades, She-Hulk became
a standout character in her own right while
also remaining a key part of the overall Hulk
legacy.
Unlike Bruce, who, as you might've heard,
had some anger issues…
"I'm always angry."
...Jen has typically been fully in control
of herself as She-Hulk, and actually preferred
her glamorous green form, fighting crime and
practicing super-powered law.
The balance of those two aspects of her character
has a lot of potential on the big and small
screens.
If you're already familiar with the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and you hear the name "Captain
Britain," you might be expecting something
very similar to Captain America, like a World
War II hero specifically crafted to be a symbolic
champion for a country in crisis.
Well, you'd be wrong.
Captain Britain's story is actually a whole
lot weirder.
Brian Braddock, was a grad student studying
physics who nearly died when the facility
he was working in was attacked by a supervillain.
As Brian bled to death, Merlin yes, that Merlin
approached him and asked him if he would become
Britain's champion, which would save his life.
Braddock was given a choice between the Amulet
of Right and the Sword of Might, and he chose
the Amulet.
As a result, he was transformed into Captain
Britain, a superhero who guards his home nation
and, by extension, the world with his mystical
superhuman enhancements.
The mystical nature of his origins, plus the
fact that there's actually a whole corps of
Captain Britain that protect the Marvel multiverse
from threats like the Fury, a super-terminator
that only exists to kill superheroes, would
make for a strange and wonderful journey in
live-action.
Ask any Thor fan which character they're still
most eager to see onscreen, and Beta Ray Bill
will almost always be at the top of the list.
Created by writer and artist Walt Simonson
in 1983, Bill first appeared as a new adversary
for the god of thunder, but became something
much more than a simple enemy when he lifted
Thor's hammer, Mjolnir, and was found worthy
of the thunder god's power himself.
As readers got to know him, Bill's tragic
story became clear.
He was a member of an alien race whose home
was destroyed by the fire giant Surtur.
Bill was chosen as the great champion who
would lead his people to a new home, and he
was given cybernetic enhancements in a painful
procedure that led to his ferocious appearance.
Though Thor at first saw him as a threat,
Bill quickly proved himself to be an honorable,
well-intentioned warrior who was capable of
fighting as one of Thor's allies.
He proved to be such a good guy, in fact,
that Odin even made him his own hammer, Stormbreaker.
Bill's exploits made him a fan-favorite character,
and it's definitely time for him to make the
leap to live-action.
Part of Monica Rambeau's origin story has
already been told in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, because she appeared as a young
girl in 2019's Captain Marvel.
Nicknamed "Lt. Trouble" by Carol Danvers,
Monica was the daughter of Carol's close friend,
Maria, so she's a kind of niece to the superheroine.
"Auntie Carol?
Mom!
It’s Auntie Carol.
I knew it.
Everyone said you were dead.
But we knew they were lying."
We know that Rambeau is showing up in the
Disney+ series WandaVision, but if she doesn't
get her superhero start there, then there's
always a possibility this child of the '90s
could come into her own in a Captain Marvel
sequel.
Either way, her comic book origin is pretty
awesome.
In Marvel Comics, Monica Rambeau was bombarded
with extra dimensional energy from a weapon
created by a rogue scientist.
As a result, she's able to transform herself
into a being of pure energy across the electromagnetic
spectrum.
This power has granted her a phenomenal level
of strength, even when compared to other superheroes,
and she's wielded it well.
Monica has led the Avengers at certain points
in her comics career, and she's seen many
different aliases, including her time as the
second Captain Marvel and her current codename,
Spectrum.
Seeing her fight side-by-side with Carol would
be a wonderful development.
We just need the origin story.
Ms. Marvel is one of the most popular new
Marvel characters in the mainstream media
of the past decade.
She's already appeared in video games, toy
lines, and animated shows, and is now set
to find her way into live-action via a Disney+
series soon.
It’s probably high time that her origin
story made it onto a screen someplace.
After all, we're living in a time when superhero
movies have sparked the most intense fandom
in years, which makes Ms. Marvel herself one
of the easiest heroes for young fans to relate
to.
Kamala Khan is a Pakistani-American girl who
grew up in New Jersey and developed various
nerdy interests, including a love of various
superheroes, particularly Carol Danvers, who
in the comics was originally named Ms. Marvel.
One night, Kamala was exposed to the Terrigen
Mist that gives the Inhumans their powers,
revealing the she herself had Inhuman blood
and was capable of gaining super powers herself
through "Terrigenesis."
When she emerged again, Kamala found that
she suddenly had the ability to morph her
body into any shape she could imagine, from
stretching out her limbs to "embiggened" size
to enlarging to completely altering her appearance.
With her newfound powers, she took up the
name of Ms. Marvel and began to fight crime.
It's a great story, born out of superhero
fandom, and it'll be great to see some version
of it arrive on the screen someday soon.
Amadeus Cho was created to infuse the Marvel
Universe with a new dose of youthful energy,
in the vein of Spider-Man.
Since his debut in 2004, he's gone on to become
one of the most consistently entertaining
young heroes on the roster, and one whose
story has a whole lot of twists and turns.
The son of Korean immigrants, Amadeus displayed
signs of a near-superhuman intellect from
a very early age.
When he was a teenager, he entered a quiz
contest for young geniuses and easily won.
Unfortunately, the contest was actually a
trap for an evil mastermind named Pythagoras
Dupree to uncover and then kill people who
might prove smarter than him.
Amadeus' family was killed in the resulting
attempt on his life, and he ended up on the
run.
While trying to make his way in the world,
he made some pretty powerful friends, first
traveling with the Hulk, and then with Hercules.
He's since become much, much more than simply
a super genius, including taking over for
both of those heroes as the Prince of Power
and the Totally Awesome Hulk.
The idea of a kid whose only crime is being
really, really smart getting swept up in a
world of superheroes and villains with such
sudden ferocity is compelling in the same
way that Spider-Man's story is.
It also gives Marvel Studios an opportunity
to give Bruce Banner a new person to play
mentor to as the MCU continues to grow and
expand.
The comics have even figured out one of the
hardest parts, which is making super-intelligence
a power that works visually.
Plus, since his mom shows up in Age of Ultron,
we already know that he exists in the MCU.
Hopefully, it's only a matter of time before
Amadeus himself makes an appearance on the
screen.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.